hey everyone everyone watching thank you
so much for featuring my ideas and my
thoughts I've been following you for a
long long time so I'm really excited to
see this come together if you really
want to achieve something you'll find a
way and if you don't you'll find excuses
I grew up in a family where you can
either be a doctor a lawyer or a failure
those are my three options anything else
would just count me as a failure I love
that I doubt myself and I hope I never
stopped the motivation watch a talk
tender with believe nation what's that
belief nation it's Evan I believe in you
and this channel is designed to be a
part of your daily success routine so
let's get your motivation to attend and
get you believing in you grab a snack
and chew in today's lessons from a man
who went from being a rebellious kid
growing up to studying and becoming a
monk in India and Europe to now using
his wisdom to inspire millions of people
around the world he's Jay Shetty and
here's my take on his top 50 rules for
success
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one to be exposed to new experiences at
18 I was really fortunate when I met a
monk and this monk was invited to speak
and I kind of just went because one of
my friends forced me to at that time I
was listening to CEOs and entrepreneurs
and business people and marketers who
who I thought that's what I was aspiring
to be like and then I hear this monk and
he captivated me like no one had ever
captivated me before it was like staring
at the most beautiful woman on the
planet you know I was completely fixated
on him and his message see we live in
echo chambers we're just surrounded by
the same thinking how often do you bump
into a monk you know it just doesn't
happen you don't have no one has a
dinner party and goes oh yeah we do this
invite the monk you know from the tower
like the local monk like no one ever
does that and so you meet people who are
just like us most of the time and we
talked about this in business bulletin
if you want to be a billionaire spend
time with billionaires if you want to be
a millionaire spent on millionaires if
you want to be a tech startup spend time
if you know that's that's the common
rhetoric that we hear all the time but
what if you want to find purpose and
master the mind there's no one better
than a monk who's mastered the mind so
for me the first step is just opening
yourself up to new experiences and new
role models because most of us can't see
ourselves in people so then we try and
fit ourselves into the boxes that we do
see and and I mean there's this
beautiful quote that I've been saying it
everywhere and I wish I wrote it but I
didn't so it's by a philosopher and
writer named Cooley and he said that
today I'm not what I think I am I'm not
what you think I am I am what I think
you think I am I understand that blow
your mind from that it's so powerful I'm
not what I think I am I'm not what you
think I am I am what I think you think I
am so we live in this perception of a
perception of ourselves
hence my identity is made by what my
parents think I should be my identity is
made up by what my college or university
thinks I should achieve
while you're living in that bubble and
that echo chamber getting to what you
really want to do is impossible because
maybe that just doesn't fit and I think
so many people feel that way today that
they don't fit into the current
education system they don't fit with the
three or four or five careers that
you're taught exist so that process of
self excavation and actualization first
requires being exposed you can't be what
you can't see if I never saw a monk I
would never have wanted to be a monk if
I never meet a billionaire I wouldn't
want to be one because I wouldn't know
what that feels like I don't know what
it looks like I don't know what it takes
and I think that's the biggest challenge
of our society that we're not exposed so
that's the first step being exposed to
unique experiences and role models
second step is finding that experience
of role model that you're passionate
about and exactly like you said taking
it seriously
shadow the network with them spend time
with them observe them even from afar it
takes that observation being addicted to
observing that person's lifestyle and
then the third step is growing yes or
not does that work for me not everyone
who's gonna go off from become a monk is
gonna feel like the way I did and that's
cool but not everyone is gonna go and
follow and shadow a billion anger that's
exactly the lifestyle I want they may
want the result but do they want the
hard work that goes with it and so for
me that's the third step
it's observing focusing shadowing
getting as close to the process of that
individual and then going yes or no do I
want that process not do I want the
result everyone's to be that monk who's
fully enlightened you know can walk
through as an incredible or that people
just gravitate towards but when you
realize he has to wake up at 2:00 a.m.
every day and sleeps about four to six
hours you're like ah you know I don't
want to do that doesn't sound like me
rule number two believe second thing we
usually get wrong is that we don't
believe in what we're sharing I've
realized that I've grown much more
confident about speaking in front of
people and even in front of you right
now on video because I talk about stuff
that's really meaningful to me that's
really purposeful to me I only choose to
share message
is that truly resonate with my heart and
my head and my intelligence and things
that I've immersed myself in for a
number of years
everything I'm sharing these stories
these ideas they aren't just made up to
sound good these are things that I
really truly try and live and practice
and embody in my own day-to-day life and
therefore if you don't really believe in
what you're speaking about if you don't
really understand it if you haven't
tried to live it then you're always
going to struggle trying to articulate
it and even if you get away with
articulating something perfectly that
you don't believe in you'll feel empty
inside and that's why sales rolls
usually end up making people feel quite
empty because they're selling stuff and
products that they don't think will
change your life make sure if you're
trying to communicate a message for your
brand if you're trying to sell a product
if you're sharing insights and ideas
they have to be things that genuinely
connect with you internally this feels
weird yeah are you sure this is legal
rule number three refine your intention
my daily practice is to refine my
intention that the biggest weeds that we
all get is an eye intention so when I
say intention I mean my current
intention is to use everything I've been
given everything that I have in the
service of others so I want to use the
following that I have to help people I
want to use the money that I have to
help people I want to use the network
that I have to help people but every day
that intention which is a beautiful
little plant that's growing gets weeds
around it no do it for the money right
to for the fact just do it for the fame
do it for the followers do it for this
all these weeds are like going around my
real intention every day every day
that's a weed a weed is the intention
that you don't want and the problem is
sometimes you've let it grow so much the
weed looks like the plant right weed
looks like your intention and you start
believing it's the same thing so for me
my daily practice is going back in
reflecting on what is my voice right now
in my head what am I saying to myself
and I'm hearing make that deal it makes
a lot of money do this do that do this
more followers fame all that stuff and
I'm cutting it down I'm cutting that
weed every day and you got to do it
every day because the more you're
surrounded by that
right the morning creepin in like a
creeper weed rule number four know your
element environment and energy so for me
my three e's are element environment and
energy every one has an element that
they thrive in if you take someone out
of it their element they won't be the
same modern-day example would be Michael
Jordan he was incredible at basketball
you took him out of basketball put them
into baseball
no one will numbers his career we talk
about one of the best athletes of all
time your environment is the environment
around you you can take a fish out of
water and give it a beautiful mansion
and a Bentley and all the money in the
world but it would die and that's what
we are like our environment everyone is
an environment which they thrive which
we have to craft your boss if you're at
work is never gonna ask you what
environment you succeed in right like
that never happens so we have to create
an environment where we thrive and then
finally its energy we some of us love
high energy environments high pressure
some of us succeed in low energy
environments and low pressure figuring
out your energy and the frequency on
which you operate best will help you
thrive as well so for me those are the
three e's to really create a thriving
environment know your element know your
environment and know your energy and so
on all times if I see anything going
wrong I'm going is my element out of
alignment is my environment out of
alignment or is my energy out of
alignment that's a great three question
test you can do to yourself when you
don't think things are going right and
all you have to do is bring that back
into alignment remember five practice
you usually don't practice enough I
realized that if you really want to be
good at something you have to invest in
it with all your life you have to become
addicted and absorb to improvement and
growth that means being open to feedback
that means being open to what the
experts have to say about you it means
not being attached to your ego
and how you feel about yourself but
opening up yourself to an expert group
of people to give you insights on how
you can grow evolve and perform at a
higher rate and linked to that is
practice practice practice
it's literally impossible to do
something perfectly the first time you
do it the more you do it the better you
get
and we think practice is a cliche that
we hear all the time but actually it's
that truth it's so simple you might miss
it did I miss something here rule number
six make it happen right now I'd like
you to fast forward to 70 80 90 years
old right fast forward in your mind to
that age 70 80 90 100 110 if you're
really optimistic whichever one it is
and I'd like you to write down what will
be the things that you'll regret that
you didn't do imagine you're that age
ask yourself the question what would I
regret that I didn't do know what you
did do but what you didn't do write it
down make a long list right now get a
pen and paper out and write it down
don't do on your phone don't do on your
laptop actually get a pen and paper and
write down your answers and what will be
the things that you regret that you
didn't do right really think about it
would it be you know learning a new
language will it be moving home will it
be telling someone you love them what
will it be what would have been write it
down right now
now the incredible thing about this
question is that you're using the future
to empower the past whatever answer you
have in that question whatever your
answer is you can do it right now today
starting today because you're not that
agent and if you're even if you're 64
and you're tuning in 70 80 90 you're
still there right it's still possible
you can start doing that right now it's
empowering the present with the future
there is nothing stopping you from
making it happen right now you don't
have to feel that way when you're 70 you
don't have to feel that way when you're
80 you never ever have to feel that way
if you start doing it right now and you
can do it right now even if it feels
impossible you can start working on it
right now you can start trying right now
you can start making plans right now
because you're not there yet and this is
where you start this is where you start
making
it happened it's all in the now rule
number seven find your passion so how do
I find my passion my simple model which
is the Dharma model it also dharma means
eternal duty in the Vedic tradition it's
very similar to what a guy is being
spoken about today which is a Japanese
version of reason for being why do we
live where is meaning coming from and it
talks about an intersect of four areas
what am I good at what do I love what is
the world need and how do I get paid for
it to me those four help you unlock your
passion when you find the intersect
across all of those four you're making
your passion your purpose you'll unlock
your passion you'll find your purpose
this is path one there's two paths path
one I find my skill set and I engage it
to help other people and become better
at it so I'm becoming better what I'm
good at and I'm using it to help other
people because I'm aware of what I'm
quite good at and I know what more
knowledge I have what skills I have I
have some self-awareness the other path
that people often miss is actually I
just start serving people I just start
helping people and I start to notice
what I enjoy about that and what I'm
good at helping people with so that's
Gandhi's part Gandhi said that you find
yourself when you lose yourself in the
service of others so for me those are
the two paths of how do I find my
passion and finding the intersect
between those four areas rule number
eight overcome challenges you have to
remind yourself that it's okay to feel
the way you feel when you're going for a
difficult time it's okay to feel weak
it's okay to want to cry it's okay to
feel overwhelmed just reminding yourself
that it's okay this is my number one way
of how to find strength in difficult
times is reminding yourself that the way
you feel is okay to honor that feeling
to accept that feeling to actually be
okay with that what we see or what we
perceive to be a weakness or what we
perceive to let us down or what we
perceive is a sign of you know
instability or insecurity we've got to
remind ourselves that when things are
tough it's okay to feel that way there's
nothing wrong with that any difficulty I
go to I look to moments in history where
people
have enjoyed the same pain if not more
extreme and analyzed absorb and connect
with how they got through it I like to
see what they were thinking I like to
see what they did I like to see how they
structured themselves I like to look at
how they organized I looked like to look
at who they were speaking to I like to
look at what was going through their
mind at that time because you've got to
remember that any challenge we're facing
today we've faced it before as as
humanity right beyond ethnicities beyond
color race creed beyond backgrounds
beyond all walks of life as human beings
we've been through challenges before and
we've got through them and therefore
reconnecting with how that's been done
before is a beautiful way of learning
how to overcome current challenges so
you can either look at your past but
real wisdom lies in looking at the past
of people who made a difference you look
at people like Martin Luther King you
look at people like Gandhi you look at
people who made world-changing
differences not single-handedly but
influenced from a single perspective
from a single point of view and really
connecting with the powerful moments in
history I've said this quote many times
I've read it many times and this quote
actually is is unbelievable and the
quote says that they fought they buried
us they didn't know we were seeds right
it's a Mexican Bravo they thought they
borrowed us they didn't know we were
seeds and I was thinking these when you
tell yourself that story
you start thinking much more differently
right a seed is buried - it's incredible
that the seed goes through the same
process as anything else it's put deep
underground right all of this mud is put
on top of it it gets rained on it gets
snowed on all these kind of things but
it knows that it's a seed so it knows
that it can grow so there anything's
possible and it grows through and you
see even plants growing through concrete
sometimes right it's unbelievable how
much power a seed has so changing the
stories we tell ourselves we can either
look at challenging situations as
opportunities for growth as an
opportunity to learn as an opportunity
to change be the change we can look at
them
and really fool down now that that
second part is okay we can even feel
like that right but we have to recognize
it's not permanent
we've gotta accept that none of our
feelings are permanent they don't need
to be permanent it's a choice so if you
need to vent vent I was saying to
someone yesterday if you need a vent
vent if you need to run run if you need
to complain complain if you need to
share how you feel do that but recognize
that those feelings are not permanent
and it'll be amazing when we've realized
we are seeds right that is the most
powerful way of finding strength rule
number nine redefine failure in the
middle of 2009 he was the software
engineer that no one wanted to hire he
had 12 years of experience at Yahoo but
he was rejected by Facebook and then
rejected by Twitter
he'd been to a great university he had a
great CV but he decided to team up with
one of his alumni members at Yahoo and
started to create an app and focus on
the startup space in five years time he
sold that out for 19 billion dollars to
Facebook believe it or not that was
Brian Acton the co-founder of whatsapp
when he was rejected from Facebook he
said it was a great opportunity to
connect with some fantastic people I
look forward to life's next adventure
when he was rejected by Twitter he
responded by saying worked out it was
quite a long commute it's so interesting
to see that someone rejected from two of
the top internet companies actually
responded with humor and actually
responded with positivity this lady was
diagnosed with clinical depression her
marriage had failed and she was jobless
with a dependent child she was on a
four-hour delay train journey from
Manchester to London when she came up
with this idea and she started to write
this book about this wizard and as she
started writing she then finished her
manuscript to get the 12 publishers and
was rejected by all of 12 believe it or
not that's JK Rowling this man watched
his first company crumble he was a
Harvard University dropout and his first
company's demo didn't even work he went
on to build Microsoft his name's Bill
Gates
therefore failure is just a sign that we
need to widen our scope we
to be ready and build ourselves up for
the next level actually what we end up
achieving is far greater than what we'd
envisioned for ourselves and this divine
plan this orchestration can't be
happening without this intervention that
occurs because if we had it our way we
just settle we just accept what we
thought was our goal what we thought we
were chasing but actually I've noticed
that when you don't get that later down
the line you look back and you reflect
and realize that what you've gained is
so much greater failures only failures
when we don't learn from them because
when we learn from them they become
lessons and we actually extract a lay
all of these teachings and actually get
more insight into how we can improve the
way we work and how we can actually
drive with a different energy the
challenge we have is that we only talk
about people's failures when they
succeed and that's why they become this
taboo or we feel like their failures
never happened we need to share these
stories earlier we need to bring out
these stories and experiences on the
journey so that people who are on the
journey can actually follow in those
footsteps
and that's why Steve Jobs said you can't
connect the dots moving forward
you only can when you're looking
backwards rule number ten decide to be a
pilot in life you're either a passenger
or a pilot you've got that choice this
is one of the biggest choices you'll
ever make are you defining what
direction you're moving in or are you
letting other people make the biggest
decisions of where you're going see it
first is more comfortable being the
passenger you sit back
have people serve you it feels easier it
feels more natural but then as time goes
by you look outside the window and you
realize you've ended up somewhere that
you didn't want to be then you start
blaming people around you blaming people
who made those decisions for you playing
people who should take responsibility
for what you've ended up sometimes you
feel lost confused and wonder how you
ever got there and in that moment at
that time you've got this important
choice to make
you can either switch seats grab hold of
the steering wheel and start guiding
your life or remain a passenger you
can't be both which one are you real
number 11 have a plan how many of you
have a crazy dream or a crazy goal I
want you to write our in the comments
section what is your crazy dream the
dream that keeps you up at night is the
real dream you should be chasing but to
chase that dream to find that dream to
make that dream a reality you need a
strategy why a dream without a plan is
just a wish Tony Robbins said that right
a dream without a plan is just a wish
right without a strategy without a
guiding philosophy without guiding
principles without actually creating a
clear plan I used to have this economics
teacher and I want you to think back to
school as well maybe you had one I
remember this economics teacher he
walked in to the classroom and the first
thing that you were on the board he
didn't even tell us his name we'd even
know who he was and he turned up he went
inside the classroom and he wrote on the
board
he said failing to prepare is preparing
to fail and all of us just burst how
laughing this guy I don't even told us
his name yet but on the board he wrote
failing to prepare is preparing to fail
and now when I look back at that and as
I grew up and hopefully became a bit
more mature than I was in high school I
remember thinking about that statement I
thinking how true is that then when
you're not prepared for something you
miss out on unbelievable opportunities
now I'm not saying good things don't
happen spontaneously sometimes things
happen by chance randomly etc with a
reason but when you're prepared you can
capitalize on things in a huge huge way
rule number 12 live in your element
play to your own element don't try and
perform someone else's expertly so in
modern terminology or how would I say
that is don't waste your time Steve Jobs
don't waste your time trying to live
someone else's life you know don't be
trapped by Dogma focus in on your own
strengths your own element what you have
to offer don't get lost in trying to
become like someone else or pretend to
be someone else there's a beautiful one
of my favorite quotes by Einstein and
then Steve Jobs again Einstein said if
you judge a fish by its ability to climb
a tree they'll spend its whole life
believing that it's stupid and too many
of us are fish trying to climb a tree
too many of us am monkeys being taught
how to swim too many of us are lions
being taught to live like cats we're not
getting to live in our element so my
second piece of advice is live in that
element that you've naturally been given
don't try adopt another you know we've
more got a special genius inside of us
it was Steve Wozniak and Steve Jobs this
conversation Steve Wozniak looked Steve
Wozniak for those who don't know is the
tech guy behind Apple he practically
invented the technology and the software
and everything so Steve Wozniak looked
at Steve Jobs and he says this is in
Walter Isaacson's biography of Steve
Jobs Steve wasn't I wasn't at looks at
Steve Jobs and he says what do you even
do said you're not a coder you're not a
designer you know what a marketer and
you're not an engineer what do you even
do imagine challenging Steve Jobs and
Steve Jobs replies he says he says
musicians play their instruments I play
the orchestra that is the most deep
understanding of one's role in life and
not getting lost in other people's
identities and perceptions of you Steve
Jobs knew that he wasn't a marketer he
wasn't an engineer he wasn't a coder so
he hired all of those but he played the
orchestra he brought it all together and
that's when you when you find confidence
in your own role you won't be envious of
anyone else rule number 13
don't let failure stop you joining a
research experiment a shark was placed
into a large tank of water and
some small fish were released into that
tank and you would expect the shot
quickly swam around the tank what's the
fish and then ended up eating all of
them then a strong piece of fiberglass
was inserted into the tank this would
create a division between where the
shark started and where the smaller fish
started again the shot quickly attacked
but they stunned the shark went in
straight into the fiberglass divider and
bounced off it tried this several times
again and again and again until it
became tired and weakened meanwhile the
fish on the other side of the divider
carried on swimming peacefully after
about an hour the shark finally gave up
this experiment was repeated several
dozen times over the next few weeks
where the shot became less aggressive
every single time it got to the point
where the shot stopped trying to attack
and eat the fish that's who the
fiberglass was then removed out of the
tank and to their amazement the shark
still did not attack the shark had been
trained through habit that a fiberglass
divider was there and that he would
bounce off and therefore didn't even
consider it at the same time the small
fish freely swam wherever they wanted
the moral of the story many of us are
experiencing setbacks and failures in
everyday life eventually we get
emotionally drained tired unmotivated
and we stop trying like the shark in the
story we believe that because we've been
unsuccessful in the past that that
barrier still exists even for new
ventures
in other words we continue to see a
barrier in our heads that separates us
from our dreams even though there is no
rule barrier between where we are and
where we want to go and remember this
the teacher has failed more times than
the student has even tried Lima 14
believe in your mission Fred Smith was
an undergraduate at Yale University in
1965 as part of his coursework he wrote
an economics paper exploring the
transportation of goods in the United
States it's how things get delivered to
you and me he found that shippers were
transporting large packages and items
either via truck or through passenger
airplanes he thought he had a more
efficient method
he wrote a last-minute paper as you do
about how a company transporting small
items via airplane would be a much
better business model because he was
rushed he never really got around to
explaining in the paper how that company
with one and he ended up getting a C the
funny thing is he still didn't give up
and in 1971 he actually launched the
company he was speaking about but within
three years of founding the company
Federal Express as it was called was
actually on the verge of bankruptcy they
were losing over a million a month that
was because of rising fuel costs
competitors in the same market and at
its zenith it was only worth about
$5,000 Smith even made a final pitch to
General Dynamics hoping for more funding
whose rejected most people at this point
probably would have just shot down
projection the great C losing a million
a month but Fred Smith had different
ideas Smith actually ended up flying to
Las Vegas that weekend with all of what
the company had the $5,000 the Monday
morning after the company had $32,000
thanks to his blackjack skills that
money made it possible to cover fuel
costs for just a few days more soon
after the company was able to raise
significant funds he went around to
multiple places to find sponsors
investors people that believed
what he was trying to achieve as a
service the amazing thing is that he was
creating a company that we all know
today it's called FedEx it now operates
in over 220 countries and has an annual
revenue of over 45 billion dollars the
interesting lesson that we can learn
here is that there were countless
occasions in Fred Smith's life where he
could have said that's it it's not
working for me he could have stopped
when he got that C for the paper he
could have stopped when he was losing a
million a month he could have even
stopped when he finally only had enough
to just last a few more days but he
believed in his vision he had believed
he had conviction about his idea and the
process and the service that he was
creating and that's the lesson here if
you really want to achieve something you
find a way and if you don't you'll find
excuses rule number 15 have a strong why
I think Mark Zuckerberg said it
brilliantly at Harvard he was saying
that finding your purpose isn't enough
you have to help other people find this
and I know you're passionate about this
whatever that definition is but it has
to lead everyone so if I'm whether I
meet a celebrity and entrepreneur or
whether I meet somebody starting out I'm
always asking them a question how can
you use what you have to make a
difference in the life of other people
yeah because if you start there
everything else will work out but if
you're starting from the point of what
am I gonna get then you're always gonna
feel disconnected and then I see that I
see people who live like that and feel
pain in their lives every day I see that
it's not like some conceptual philosophy
we see it I see people who are only in
it for themselves and they feel
disconnected dissatisfied every single
day and then you see the other extreme
where people are just trying to give too
much more than they even have themselves
and they also feel disconnected and
again nothing at all nothing at all
right so we know it again attachment and
aversion two sides of the same coin
mm-hmm so we want to be in that dynamic
balance of growth but always to give
yeah so I always think how can I go
three steps deeper so that I can move
three steps forward so I can give three
times as much right it's all that's
always my mentality how do I go deeper
to go more forward to give more yeah and
if I can get those three in action for
that reason see it's what about the we
you can do anything you like but it's
why are you doing it worse
rule number 16 train like underdogs
now it's incredible that we root for
underdogs it's incredible that we want
underdogs to win why because we're used
to wanting our team to win we're used to
wanting the best to win we're used to
wanting to associate ourselves with
people who are successful right
we never go oh yeah I know someone who
plays for that really bad team like we
don't say that right we say things like
oh I know so many place was that really
good team I know someone who was MVP I
know someone who's the son or the
daughter of the MVP we try and associate
or link ourselves to success and when we
do that it in turn makes us feel more
successful it's one of the reasons why
when your team wins you say we won right
you say we won but when someone asks you
or how did your team do and if they lost
that day you say they lost you rarely
say we lost it's incredible how
psychologically we distance ourselves
from failure and we close an or like on
ourselves to success but the exception
to that rule is the underdog we all get
excited by underdogs we all get
motivated by underdogs we feel
completely enamored by the story of the
underdog push on underdogs are just
simple-minded they don't have
expectations and don't have anything to
prove to anybody and push on you've just
hit the nail on the head that's the
principle I'm trying to get across
actually we should play like champions
and train like underdogs why because the
underdog works in a way not worrying
about what anybody else thinks or
believes that gives you an edge it gives
you a phenomenal advantage when you're
actually worried about what will people
say when you're not concerned by am I
going to fail am I'm going to look worse
is what I'm doing not going to succeed
as an underdog you don't let those
things cloud your mind you can focus in
on the task at hand see when we become
successful even as underdogs if we've
risen to success the biggest enemy of
that success the biggest Achilles hero
the biggest thing that can trip us up is
not me connecting to that feeling of and
so no matter how much success you've
achieved no matter where you are always
remind yourself the mindset of an
underdog is the mindset that nurtures
talent that nurtures success that
harnesses your true potential rule
number 17 go through hurdles this man
began singing and playing the guitar at
age four his parents didn't want him to
watch too much television he was banned
from playing video games but he had a
lot of books about art he didn't enjoy
school and was even bullied at age 15 a
year later he decided to quit school and
follow his dreams of making in the music
industry now things didn't go as planned
he ended up homeless sleeping often on
trains just to get by this lasted for
around three years where he had nowhere
to live
he spent multiple nights and days
performing to small groups often without
even eating to his surprise some of his
tracks went viral on iTunes even
reaching the number-two spot on the
iTunes chart by the end of the year his
album had sold 800 and 1000 copies
making it the eighth best-selling album
of the year his latest song was one of
the most listened to worldwide his name
ed Sheeran today he's mentored by Elton
John Paul McCartney says that he's a fan
he's even written songs for Taylor Swift
in one direction and many many more Ed's
story teaches us that there's no such
thing as an overnight success he was so
shocked and surprised when his album
went viral online but when you look at
the struggle before that you see the
pain he had to go through often we only
view people's success as what we see in
their highlight reel and we've
get what they actually had to go through
to get to that stage and that's why the
next time you see someone that you think
is successful don't focus on what
they're doing now focus on what they did
to get them
rule number 18 grow your brand what are
the people not understanding about video
okay what are they not understanding
about how powerful it is for their
business and their brand and ultimately
their message to impact people it's
always that same question what's the ROI
on social media right what's the ROI now
the funny thing is your business work in
service my business work and service
literally lives off of social media so
there's obviously an ROI but the problem
is we live in a world where we want
everything to be measurable and there's
a beautiful Einstein code that says not
everything that counts can be counted
and not everything that you can count
counts right and we live in this world
where everything needs to be measured
like oh that video has a million views
how many cells did you get through that
but it's that life doesn't work like
that there's a lot of adverts and
billboards on the street that the
biggest brands pay for that don't
convert into direct sales do you think
that coca-cola looks at the billboard
out there and goes how many people saw
that advert today and how many people
bought coke our garlic because of that
advert they don't have that number it
doesn't exist and they're one of the
biggest brands in the world but they
still do it so social media video is
just a new billboard mm-hmm and the
biggest brands know that the more you
see it like I mean this is funny I saw
this thread so big billboard outside of
my hotel that has all the Jenners and
the Kardashians wearing their Calvin's
have you seen it I saw it straightaway
this morning then I swear on Instagram
and then I swear everywhere so already
I've seen in three places now I don't
need women's Calvera underwear but the
point is that I've seen it in a million
places so anyone who's not using video
hasn't understood that more people are
gonna see video than anything else
and noticed that video is so much better
than a billboard you can say so much
more right so for me it's just a lack of
seeing opportunity there's a there's a
great I think this is a old tale it's
not true but but it's told that when
Nike first went to India they went there
and it's not Nike it any any
and it's it's ass nice story and when
they first went to India they saw
everyone was barefoot
so the first reporter came back and said
or there's no market there because no
one wears trainers and then the second
reporter went then he said oh no one
wears shoes and then he came back and
says we've got a huge market out there
right and it's the way you see it that
someone a sword no one wearing shoes
there's no mark here but another person
swore everyone not wearing shoes as a
market right and that's what video is
that you can sit here and debate the RO
and video for as long as you want but
the truth is every major brand has
invested in a front window that may not
translate to direct sales or work or
whatever it is man but it does you think
every brand should be using video every
brand should be using video rule number
19 choose love I'm almost 30 and I don't
feel like I've accomplished anything in
life I made a promise to myself while I
was a university that I would get a job
that excites me every morning but right
now I'm afraid I'm not going in that
direction that note was written by a
young person and when I read it my heart
sank
I felt that way because I know so many
people that are in that exact position I
remember when I decided to trade my
nine-to-five for a 24/7 it was because I
wanted to do something that was
meaningful every day I wanted to do
something that was purposeful and
fulfilling from the moment I woke up to
the moment I went to sleep the one thing
I didn't know before I started is how
achievable that was but also what it
required when I transitioned from my
nine-to-five or actually my 9:00 to 9:00
to her 24/7 I realized that I was going
to have to work harder smarter and
faster and that step was full of fear
full of anxiety full of insecurities
full of questions like what will happen
if it doesn't work what will people say
should I just have stayed where I was I
went through all of those emotions all
at the same time and then something came
to me I wrote down the various options
that I had in life at the time and
word above them that I believe summarize
the experience or the result of what I
thought that would give me some of them
said ego because I thought those career
paths would give me a boost to my ego
some said security because they were
sent roles with jobs I could take that
would provide a certain level of
financial security and then one path
said the word love because I knew if I
did that that I would love every moment
even if it was truly challenging and
sometimes really difficult to deal with
and that's why I'm here today making
this video speaking to all of you
because I chose the path that had the
word love above it try that exercise try
that activity out to try and
differentiate the motive the intention
behind what you're choosing and
selecting in life no just because you
choose the word love doesn't mean that
everything's gonna be smooth sailing and
are you going to be successful it's
going to have its own ups and downs and
that's why wherever you go with your
heart take your head with you
rule number 20 make wisdom go viral
what's the impact that you want to have
on the world
I think you've you've said it so
beautifully so many times and shared my
vision which is wonderful and it's
wonderful to know that we share the same
thing it's making wisdom go viral
there's an incredible study in 2017 that
said the most successful people in the
world healthy wealthy and wise choose
education over entertainment the impact
I want to have from the world is I want
to transform and revolutionize the
entertainment industry so that it
becomes educational without anyone
knowing so it's still completely
entertaining it's still like watching
Netflix but you're learning about human
behavior the mind neuroscience and
everything without even knowing you are
to me that's the greatest win that we
can have for our society how many people
are going to quit watching Netflix I'm
reading a book every night I don't know
but if we can make that book come to
life on Netflix that's going to change
the world because that's what people are
going to consume so for so long
media has been used to numb people to to
switch people off if we can use it to
excite elevate enlighten people not by
just not by like the cheesy way of like
well let's follow someone through their
journey of enlightenment or like that
kind of stuff I mean like really
entertaining programming where you can
learn by being entertained at the same
time if I can do that by changing the
most powerful industry in the world then
I will feel that I've had some Sun
whatever an impact because that way I
think will reach the world without
having to get run to change their habits
too much my my thing is how do we meet
people where they are and and really
deliver a message and a powerful
expression of love and to me that's the
highest form of compassion the highest
form of empathy love and compassion is
to meet people where they already are
rather than expecting them to change
rule number 21 stop caring what others
think you'll feel that rejection kills
dreams we all feel that failure kills
dreams we all feel that people kill
dreams you can't kill my dreams but
actually there's four words that we say
in our heads to ourselves that genuinely
have destroyed more dreams than all of
those things put together those four
words are what will people say what will
people say how many times have you
stopped yourself from doing something
because you're scared of how people will
react how many times out of the fear of
someone else's opinion or criticism have
you stopped yourself from doing what you
believe in how many times has someone's
perception or perspective stopped you
from living your potential no matter
what you choose to do they
always be people and find fault with it
there will always be people who
criticize complain you try to bring you
down and tell you that what you're doing
isn't right
haters gonna hate it's crazy that we
give up what we most want in life just
based on people's opinions and the crazy
thing is if we're living for other
people's opinions we'll never be right
there'll always be someone with
something that they won't agree with and
this is why it's so important that we
work with our own conviction we work on
what matters to us it was Aristotle who
told us that there were only three ways
to avoid criticism do nothing say
nothing be nothing and I'm sure none of
us want that of our future
rule number 20 to live fully when we die
our life line does this right it looks
like this when you're living your life
lines doing this notice how that
connects with our real experience of
life real life is ups and downs stagnant
life death looks like this being an
entrepreneur looks like this
one's living ones dead you choose when I
saw that I start to visualize that I
realized that every time I felt every
time things went wrong every time I
chose to risk to live my passion and
things didn't work out and they don't
work out even now they don't work out
and when I analyze the lives of
entrepreneurs and look at how things
haven't worked out I just remind myself
that's living that's not real number 23
make your life about service your
musician serve if you're a coda serve if
your orchestra leader serve if you're
entrepreneurs serve like make your life
about service and helping other people
not just to feel good but make that the
reason why you do what you do mmm don't
make that what happens because you have
money make that the reason you do what
you do yeah and if people start with
service then you'll experience love then
you'll experience compassion then you'll
experience gratitude services Ghandi
said that you find yourself when you
lose yourself in the service of others
and and that's the deepest level of
self-actualization so know that you're
the soul and the consciousness not the
body know that you have a unique genius
and don't settle for any less and use
both of those to serve other people as
the reason for the first two rule number
24 by aura ties growth
I remember this video that went viral
around two years ago with this young
girl around two years old started to
crawl and walk in her parents living
room she went up to the television
screen and she decided to try and get it
to swipe she started doing this with
little hands and fingers hoping that the
television screen would swipe to her
complete bewilderment the television
screen did not swipe Oh
all of a sudden tears started to run
down her eyes because she in her two
year old life had never come across the
screen that didn't swipe it doesn't work
what do you mean it doesn't work it
doesn't work she probably used her
parents iPad or laptop she used her
parents screen and she'd been seeing
screen swipe for two years but this
screen did not swipe in two years she
had developed a belief that every screen
in her life swipes imagine if in two
years
she was completely conditioned to
believe that every screen swipes how
quickly we all become conditioned in two
decades for decades six decades or even
more they say that the biggest challenge
today is not simply to learn but to
learn unlearn and we learn wait what so
I want you to think about in your mind
the one habit that you want to change
now if you truly want to change your
habit
psychologists and researchers say it
will take anywhere from 21 to 90 days if
you want to change anything in your life
you have to start with a small step but
make it a big priority one of the
biggest mistakes people make is they try
to make big changes and make them a
small priority I had a bad boys rule
number 25 don't settle
what happened in societies that were
clouded by the noise the noise of family
expectations the noise of our parents I
grew up in a family where you can either
be a doctor a lawyer or a failure
those are my three options anything else
would just count me as a failure right
I'm standing up here in front of you all
as a failure we focus so much on life in
what we want to be as opposed to who we
want to be we've always been told that
life and jobs and careers are like boxes
and containers there's only a finite
number of options you can decide right
now that I don't want to be defined by
this box I don't want to be defined by
this container I don't want to feel that
if only I live in this container then
I'll be able to be successful renumber
26 find self-awareness most of us just
throw ourselves into the deep end and
then try swim and figure it out right
monke life actually begins at like five
years old like the training of mountain
life is ultimately training in
self-actualization and self-awareness
it's meant to start when you're five the
problem is we all went to normal schools
that try to put stuff in us rather than
takes a damask rose you talk about this
right right like you know you were told
at school that you weren't very good and
you won't go to English and now you have
a New York Times bestseller right yeah
and it and it's like but no one noticed
that potential inside you no one noticed
that or Lewis was really creative Wow
and you're not the only person there's
so many people who feel like that so the
modern schooling system didn't
extrapolate your self-actualization your
element and just try to put maths
English science inside so the point is
that you're trying to get to such a
strong foundation that when you interact
in the world you're going with a sense
of strength fuel energy to make a
difference rather than going into the
world and then going oh my god where am
I trying to figure it out
and I find what happens today is that
when you don't we all know this we I
mean self loves become such a big thing
now and when people don't figure out
yeah it's like a huge trend but but my
point is that if you don't start at a
place where you have self-awareness
self-actualization you have figured out
what works for you what your strengths
are how you want to be in an environment
when you walk out there most of us just
pretend to be someone else most of us
get lost most of us get carried away
yeah so my point is strengthen yourself
grow yourself and then of course
interact with the world rule number 27
go beyond wanting money Steve Jobs said
that you should never start a company
with the goal of getting rich it should
be about starting a company
to make something you believe it we
should clean to make a difference break
down boundaries billion borders and
ignite ideas to innovate incessantly
and create for people where they can
never cut you up themselves Henry Ford
said that if I had asked people what
they wanted they would have said faster
horses and that's the beauty of being
beyond wanting money and going beyond
wanting fame then beyond wanting power
that you actually craft something that
involves people's daily lives that you
actually create something that enhances
someone's human experience people
respond to people who want to do more
than just gain for themselves we were
attracted by selflessness we're
attracted by renunciation we're
attracted by the quality of when people
want to give rather than take and they
want to share rather than people when
they want to do and serve rather than
just hold Steve Jobs said being the
richest man in the cemetery doesn't
matter to me what matters to me is going
to sleep feeling like we've done
something wonderful
rule number 28 use your time wisely I'm
not telling you to not work at a
corporate I think corporate experience
is great what I'm saying is don't lose
this voice work to 6:00 p.m. every day
then go home and work will you actually
care about use your weekends to not be
on Instagram and actually do what you
care about you do that you're investing
in your meaning you can be making enough
money and make the switch that's what's
up for all of you who have a great
degree have a great education you've got
that job lined up use it just don't
become a servant of that job don't just
say oh I'm in prison now I'm just gonna
use my weekends to hang out if you do
want to do that that's cool too if you
say to me Jay actually whatever you're
saying I don't even want I just want to
hang out and have a good time I don't
even want me
our purpose that's cool with me too but
if you want to be happy and you want to
be fulfilled and you want to have an
impact on the world then use your time
wisely I used to go home after my
corporate job at 8 p.m. and edit to 1
a.m. on my own every day so do your job
get a job if that's where you need to go
with it you can go all in be safe be
secure but then don't waste that time on
not doing that and complaining that you
don't have what you want renumber 29
stop chasing a false reality one thing
I've been observing is that achievement
or ambition is broken down into five
stages learn experiment perform
struggles right right now the challenge
with all of those is is that we want to
thrive all the time we want to be in
thrive zone we want to be winning those
awards getting those views getting those
messages getting those lights all the
time we want to be noticed and
recognized but actually if we took a
step back we realized we need to be
learning we need to be experiment and so
what happens is that we get confused by
where we are and so our expectation of
what we want is totally blurred and we
start chasing a false reality and that's
why we find that we get disappointed and
confused
when we know we should actually be
performing we actually need to do we
need to act rather than chasing that
thriving feeling all the time so next
time you think things aren't working out
next time you feel you're not on the
right track step back and ask yourself
should I be learning should I be
experimenting should I be thriving
should I be performing or should I be
struggling that one comes around a lot
more than you can imagine
rule number 30 don't live for the
approval of others let me tell you about
this girl called clear I think you might
know someone like her too she had the
dream of becoming a model she said she
was going to move to LA
pursue it seriously she took care of
herself at least her body well someone
told me she did ads for L'Oreal she had
so many followers on Instagram who all
loved her within a minute of her posting
a picture there'll be hundreds and
hundreds of comments all telling her how
beautiful she was how good she looked
comment after comment like after like
she was a real entertainer she was
always making everyone laugh I remember
every guy wanted her number but she kept
to herself she just had this infectious
energy she got along with everyone she
was always the life of the party she was
never seen in the same outfit twice
boxes and boxes of Amazon Prime on
Instagram she was the perfect girl with
the perfect life the perfect world he
the perfect guys nothing's perfect right
it seemed like she was always having the
best time with her friends always
travelling new experiences and so many
great stories to share until people
started to notice I think she lived like
two lives no one really knew her inside
she had everyone to text but no one to
talk to everyone to follow but no one to
walk with when the phone was up her
world was a stage but it was down a
reality came she had an invite to every
event
still felt lonely she had all the
friends in the world but still felt no
one really knows me she was going
through pain but never showed that side
it was something she hid from the world
maybe we just never asked she had masked
her sadness with one look like the ideal
life she was always flying high in the
air a fellow inside her inbox who is
full but she felt empty within
she was happy on the outside but
struggling with depression and anxiety
she had an addiction that everyone
called a lifestyle she was struggling
with mental health but people were just
occupied by her physical appearance see
people think depression is sadness
people think depression is crying
people think depression is being quiet
depression is when we smile or we want
to cry it's when we talk but we want to
be quiet it's when we pretend like we're
happy but we're not
depression is not always obvious she
drank to drown her pain but the pain and
how to swim she was sick of crying tired
of trying smiling but inside she was
dying it's amazing how we can think we
know someone and still not know them at
all I don't think we understand how
stressful it is to explain what's going
on in your head when you don't even
understand yourself we use filters to
lighten our photos whilst we carry the
heavy weight of stress remember it's
okay to highlight reels but make sure
someone knows how you really feel it's
okay to use FaceTime but make sure you
spend quality time face-to-face it's
okay to have followers but make sure you
have true friends don't live for the
approval of others documen the moments
you're most in love with yourself not
just the moments you think people will
love and most when someone doesn't post
for a few days we ask if they're okay
when someone posts every day we assume
they are tell people you love them be a
trustworthy friend tell them that they
matter tell them that they've survived a
lot and they're ready to thrive now
people who care will ask how you're
doing people who love you
wait till you tell the truth and that's
why Robin Williams said I used to think
that the worst thing in life was to end
up alone it's not the worst thing in
life is to end up with people who make
you feel alone
rule number 31 never regret a day in
your life they can't control time we
can't control the future but we can
choose how we feel today we can choose
what we do today we can choose who we
meet today and where we go stop waiting
for Friday's stop waiting for summer
stop waiting for that ideal job stop
waiting for someone to spot your talent
it's not about waiting but about making
the most of each moment right now ask
yourself if this was the last day of
your life is this how you would like to
spend it mentally up here you might not
be able to change what you do but you
can change how you feel about it if you
have to spend the day at work ask
yourself how can I make it more
meaningful if you're at home with your
family
ask yourself how can I make it more
fulfilling if you're around people you
don't like move we're not trees and if
you're in a toxic environment learn to
protect yourself and no matter how
little you have or how tough things are
see where you can be grateful that book
that's been on your mind write it that
video that you've been scripting shoot
it that business that you want to launch
started that skill you've been wanting
to gain
don't wait for the perfect moment take
the moment and make it perfect never
regret a day in your life
good days give you happiness bad days
give you experience the worst days give
you lessons and the best days give you
memories rule number 32 visualize
whether it's David Beckham taking one of
his famous free kicks whether it's Lewis
Hamilton winning the formula one whether
it was Steve Jobs about to give one of
his famous keynotes the most underrated
skill was this visualization the
re-creation of images sounds and
environments before it has happened is
one of the most powerful skills in the
world a very powerful meditation and
mindfulness practice the visualization
has been used for centuries to help
prepare the mind the body and the
consciousness for upcoming challenges
situations and circumstances some of the
world's greatest athletes use
visualization as a way to prepare for
big games the big day musicians for
their new concerts and tours and CEOs
for their very important meetings
rule number 33 solve problems I noticed
in your videos that you ask a lot of
questions and I would imagine that's an
intense something that you intend to do
yeah I believe that the answers come
from within and we're not asking the
right questions I feel we're always
looking for the right answers not the
right questions and the biggest
companies that we respect today the
biggest organizations all came from
trying to answer a question hmm
it all came from trying to solve a
problem or a question that we were able
to identify so the my work comes from a
very simple study that I read that said
the most successful people in the world
choose education over entertainment and
the most unsuccessful people in the
world choose entertainment over
education with their spare time so my
mission has been how do we spread wisdom
at the pace people want entertainment
and to me entertainment allows you to
populate the thought with your own brain
like when you watch a character or a
superhero you can watch it from your own
lens
the movie may have morals in there
values and maybe to my good and evil but
the movies not deciding for you the
movie allows you a space to create and
imagine and grow so for me that's what I
want my content to do is give people a
space to populate themselves see
themselves in the characters that I'm
presenting see their own situation and
be able to come to their own conclusion
rule number 34 take responsibility just
around two years ago I had this idea I
wanted to share wisdom at a pace we
wanted entertainment I wanted to share
wisdom in a way that I could connect
resonate and deeply evolve the lives of
people all over the world for ten years
before that I'd been working with
individuals groups coaching at
universities companies and all of these
opportunities but I really wanted to
serve and connect with everyone across
the world I wanted to make wisdom
accessible to anyone who had one of
these I'm not one of those so I was
excited I had the energy the enthusiasm
and I was pitching my idea to every
single company that was online now
remember this is before I ever made a
single video before any of you knew who
I was I applied to not 10 not 20 but 30
online media companies hoping that one
of them would like my series idea I
waited the day I waited two days I
waited a week I was rejected by every
single one of those companies before
interview none of them invited me for a
phone interview none of them invited me
for a video interview none of them even
connected with me in any personal way
that's rude
I said to myself it doesn't matter let's
see what else I can do to try and make
my goal a reality what
so I tried to network with people who
may be able to give me a chance I got
one on someone answering me they said
you're getting older now most of the
people who want to break into this
industry around 21 years old just don't
worry about it other people said to me
look you need to go get a media and
journalism degree or a masters and then
we'll take you seriously literally I was
getting rejected from every single
person I spoke to but inside of me I had
this desire had this calling I had this
mission I had this vision that I wanted
to share everything that I'd learn with
people out there I genuinely tried every
single possible method I could to break
into the media industry to the point
that the only thing that was left that I
could try was to start a social media
channel and of course you know the rest
the most incredible thing is that it
reminds me of a really powerful thought
and Thomas Edison he once said when you
believe you've exhausted all options
remember this
you haven't bat for stayed in my mind
the whole time what I learned from all
of this rejection from all of this
failure from all of these clear knows
was one really important thing and today
I want to give that as a gift to you me
if you have a dream you have an idea you
have a vision we have to take the
responsibility to prove our worth before
we expect anyone to value our talent
when I started crafting and creating my
own videos teaching myself how to edit
learning how to produce understanding
the mechanics of social media when I
started putting my energy into that
space that's when people started to take
notice that's when people started to
listen
when things started to happen this is
nice it's when I decided to take the
responsibility for sharing what I was
passionate about with the world and not
waiting for someone external to validate
me
or give me permission or allow me to do
that that's what made the difference
if you're feeling you've been going
through a lot of rejections ask yourself
this is your deeper passion and calling
making you want to move further number
two have you truly knocked on every
single door and number three are you
working hard on investing in your
expertise and passion so that you really
have something impactful to offer
rule number 35 find balance there's a
beautiful works in the bhagavad-gita
that says that detachment doesn't mean
that you own nothing Oh catchment means
that nothing owns you okay and to me
that's that balance oh that's that
balance it's that you know that like if
you're going over the millions and
billions but then that starts owning you
right we've seen that destroy people
right you've seen that destructive
people so it's like the dominant energy
exact how do you think cuz it's easy to
fool yourself and be like no no no no
I'm not dominated by money but like how
it was there a litmus test is there a
test you had in the back of your mind
that you could know that you are truly
detached well I think there's you know
we have both like one of my favorite
quotes which kind of complicates the
whole whole situation is from Charles
Cooley where he said that today I'm not
what I think I am I don't know what you
think I am I am what I think you think I
am right all right and we're lost in
that perception of a perception of
ourselves yeah my billionaire mates you
tell me no man you're all right like
you've got money you're you're good but
you've got to have that reflection but
that's not gonna come if you're just
surrounded in the echo chamber yeah and
you talk about these loads adding
mentors right my thing is that when I
come up with an idea I want to know what
the Dalai Lama thinks as much as what
the Mark Zuckerberg thinks because for
me that whole era tea right is what
allows me to not get lost in the echo
chamber rule number 36 serve one of the
most beautiful things I learned was that
serving other people was without a doubt
the most meaningful experience of
humanity and there's this great study by
Michael Norton from the Cambridge
University where he talks about how
money can buy happiness if you spend it
on other people
hmm and he's got this incredible study
in all regions all across the world
where he talks about how actually if
people are given five twenty or even a
hundred dollars when you spend it on
yourself your happiness doesn't go up or
doesn't go down but when you spend it on
other people your happiness is the
opportunity to grow by at least 10 to 20
percent huh so fulfillment grows when we
use our money time energy in the service
of others and when I was working at
internships I felt like I was serving
myself and I wasn't getting an
opportunity to impact someone else's
life we've all been in that and I'm sure
you have been in that position where
you've just made a difference in a young
person's life you've made a difference
in someone who doesn't have much and you
see the joy on their face and that's
what I was getting to experience as a
monk on a daily basis rule number 37
press pause and reflect Albert Einstein
famously remarked to the conversation
with Werner Heisenberg he said you know
in the West we've built a beautiful ship
and in it it has all the comforts but
actually the one thing that it doesn't
have is a compass and that's why it
doesn't know where it's going this
parallels of our times was propounded by
the Dalai Lama when he said we have
wider freeways but narrower viewpoints
we have taller buildings but shorter
tempers which we've said that we spend
money we haven't earned and things we
don't need to impress people we don't
like and it's phenomenal how the same
technology that brings us close to those
are far away takes us far away from the
people that are actually close 30
billion whatsapp messages are sent a day
but 48 percent of people say that they
feel lonelier in general the paradox of
our times is that we have more degrees
but less sense more knowledge but less
judgment more experts but less solutions
it was Martin Luther King who said that
the irony of our time
that we have guided missiles but
misguided men have you ever found it
perplexing that we've been all the way
to the moon and back but we struggled to
start conversation across the road or
I'll cross the train and it's amazing
that Bill Gates was known as the top
earner in 2015 with a wealth of seventy
nine point two billion but one in four
ceos claimed to be struggling from
depression and do we actually thrive off
this paradox is it that this paradox
actually makes the media interesting
it's what makes journalism interesting
what makes politics in this wing is what
makes television interesting is this
paradox actually what was feed off on
what we live off and what we talk about
and discuss in our circles doesn't it
seem that we've tried to clean the air
but polluted our soul we've split the
axon but not our fridge of this and
we're aiming for higher-income Elizabeth
we have lower morals so I'm hearing you
ask how do we bring a change how do we
dissect these paradox that exists in our
lives and it starts by us each of us
pressing pause pressing reset and then
pressing play again taking a moment to
become more conscious taking a moment to
become more aware taking a moment to
really reflect on the consequence the
implications of a misplaced word of an
unnecessary argument that we all know we
didn't need to have or to speak to
someone just slightly differently in a
different tone and a different voice in
a different empathy with a different
perspective just to really connect with
people on a different level this
thinking out loud started from Albert
Einstein I'll try back to him when he
actually said that the problems we have
today can't be solved with the same
thinking we used when we once created
them so actually we need to research
alternative teachings we need to deep
down dig into those ancient books of
wisdom we need to go back to
understanding if there's anything
written in those creased pages of time
that can actually reveal more knowledge
and more wisdom of how we can transform
our experience of Lights today otherwise
this paradox means that every step
forward we take we're taking three
backwards every time rule number 38
start your day with gratitude
finding some space whether it's 10
minutes a day five minutes a day just
install the gratitude
I think that's the beginning of this
journey so what do you mean by that
right journal I'm thankful that I'm
healthy today I'm thankful that I live
in you know specific your gratitude is
the deeper it is so the more like it's
like oh I'm thankful that I breathed
which is just everyone breeds yeah the
more specific we get about our
particular situation yeah like I'm just
happy that I was able to walk into work
today and have meaningful relationships
with the people I work with
yeah or I'm just happy today that I'm
standing with Ty right that's that's a
real specific gratitude not that oh I'm
in LA and it's sunny right she was your
million people are experiencing yeah a
little bit very specific specific rule
number 39 focus on true wealth
I believe that wealth is beautiful and
brilliant it can do incredible things in
the world when used to make a difference
when we use any wealth that we have to
make an impact to use it to make an
influence to help serve and support the
lives of others but today I want to talk
to you about a different type of
richness one of my favorite teachings
about wealth has been this you can tell
how rich you are by counting the amount
of things you have that money cannot buy
there's a beautiful quote by Jim Carrey
where he says I believe that everyone
should become rich famous and achieve
everything they want just to realize
that it's not the point it would be nice
real wealth in a well fulfillment
satisfaction meaning and purpose is a
rich list that every single one of us
can have and beyond I want you to take a
moment to make a list of the things you
have
cannot buy maybe it's a beautiful family
maybe it's an incredible partner maybe
it's a passion and a drive that you've
recently found and discovered for
yourself maybe it's a recent experience
that you had that wasn't really about
where you were for more about who you
were with and what you were thinking
about the reason why I'm focusing on
this rich list is because this list is
something we often forget it's not on
the front page of a magazine it's not
inside the newspapers it's not on the
list online but this list is one that
you can look at every single day to
remind yourself how fortunate how
grateful and how incredible your life
truly is rule number 40 travel once a
year go someplace that you've never been
before Travel empowers the learner
inside of us increases our curiosity and
our humility the Journal of Personality
and Social Psychology found that kids
who study abroad were more humble than
those who didn't travel being in the
outdoors refreshes your senses in a way
that no office air ever could the latest
evidence in a new study published in the
journal environmental psychology
researchers found that people who simply
looked at a photo of nature for only 40
seconds have improved focus and
performance on their next task and this
is my favorite thought
at first travel leaves you speechless
and then it turns you into a storyteller
rule number 41 build the mini dream
first how do you know your dream is your
dream how do you go after something that
you don't know if it's actually meant
for you or not great question I think
the number one thing to do is to build
the mini dream first so before trying to
go off on this huge journey of building
this humongous dream build the mini
version of it and see what it feels like
so if you want to be someone who travels
across the world and performs travel to
one city and perform if you want to be
someone who's in movies go and film a
short movie write like go and build the
mini version of that dream because that
many dreams gonna teach you so much like
I'll give you an example I know so many
people who say to me I want to be an
actor and I'll be like okay great well
let's make a short movie and when they
make a short movie and they realize
they're up at 5 a.m. every day and that
they're in the studio on a set to 10
p.m. and they realize that set is not
very glamorous that they realize they
have to say the same line 30 times
before the director says that line is
okay if it lasted only actors anymore
because what we've fallen in love with
is what the dream looks like I know what
the dream is so my biggest advice to
anyone including myself has always been
build the mini dream and the mini dream
will teach you everything you need to
know about whether you're ready for the
big dream it's the same as sports if you
want to be a sports player wake up at 4
a.m. every day go to the gym for two
hours a day like do the actual schedule
do the actual process of the person
who's already doing it so I always say
look at what people were doing when they
were at your age not on the stage the
right now
and do that and see whether you love
that that's how you figure it out just
on a very small level rule number 42
follow your intention I've talked to
people who've succeeded and and they all
seem to have this idea of intention
mm-hmm
this idea of I'm gonna think about you
know where I'm going with my life have a
plan some people call it goal settings
sure and I just wonder if you had that
in mind that this was sort of a step
towards something else my genuine
response to that is I wanted to be among
for the rest of my life because I fought
I thought that would be my best point of
service so my intention was to serve and
to give knowledge and to give wisdom and
to give insight by studying and going
through the growth myself but it was to
do it as a monk like did I ever think I
would be on videos and social media or
even sitting with you here today no did
I ever imagine and vision a path for me
to be moving to LA or living in the u.s.
know like those one and and I speak
about that often it's interesting I
talked about how I I never really had a
vision board I never had that goal I
just had a deep intention that I wanted
to learn and share that knowledge I
didn't know what that looked like I
didn't know how it would work and I
didn't have a step-by-step process hmm I
just knew that that deeply was where I
wanted to start from rule number 43
reinvent yourself it's incredible the
amount of individuals institutions and
businesses that have absolutely being
destroyed overnight because people at
the top believed and the way they've
done it for decades is the way that
nation build in the future do it again
remember you can't get anywhere new if
you're always doing the old it's just
not possible one of my favorite examples
is about this company that had the
biggest market share they had this
opportunity to buy an economy business
now business at the time was valued at
around 50 million dollars this large
company could have bought this small
company for 50 million dollars
they said no they turned it down they
didn't believe that streaming and online
movies with the future that big company
was blockbuster and the little company
was Netflix it's incredible now where we
live in a world where Netflix it's
valued at tens of billions of dollars
and blockbuster doesn't even exist
anymore it's incredible how many
individuals institutions and businesses
have had to completely shift transform
transition and reinvent redefine and
recreate themselves to remain relevant
and this is a great message for all of
us we don't have to change who we are or
we have to redefine reinvent and
recreate our focus our skills our
priorities our abilities we always have
to recognize how what we have is
relevant for the modern world and all
the new challenges that come with it if
we choose to innovate and disrupt
ourselves we can never be disrupted if
we choose to challenge an experiment and
test and try new things then there's no
one else who can do that for us rule
number 44 smile scientists have known
for some time that changing your body
through actions like smiling sitting up
straight and relaxing can change your
mental and emotional responses when we
change our body to sit up straight to
smile to connect with others to engage
with presence we automatically change
the responses in our mind we allow
ourselves to feel better to think better
and to live better
it's incredible to know that simple
changes in our body language in the way
that we're sitting can impact our
emotional mood States so much more
insightful research has been done into
this space but if you can just take a
simple step today to change your posture
to add a smile and to relax a little
you'll see how much your mind will be at
ease rule number 45 doubt yourself you
seem to be someone with great confidence
and and and wisdom at your young age and
I wonder are there moments when you
doubt yourself when you think well this
isn't right or
you know am i doing the right thing or
am i am i creating the right message
today hugely and I think that that's a
practice that I hope I never lose
because I think that's the practice that
makes you want to learn more it makes
you want to refine your message and it
also stops you from putting out content
for pressure so I think we live in the
world especially on social media where
there's such a pressure to put out
content a volume and to keep up with
everyone else's videos and numbers going
up and views and for me that checking
system that you just spoke about that's
what helps me step back and go do I
really believe this or did it just sound
good for a moment and so I hope I always
keep that that doubt I find it as a
valuable tool and I'm always going
around in that process I had that
recently where I've really I got offered
book deals from everywhere I could have
ever dreamed of after my first video and
viral and I've resisted signing with
anyone because my personal goal is to
write a book that acts you believe in
I'm not right there just because it's
going to sell well and so a lot of
people are like you're taking too long
it you know but I'm just like but it's a
book like people are gonna pay money and
spend their time to read this book the
content has to have substance yeah and I
have to really feel like I've crafted
something of value hmm so I love that I
love that I doubt myself and I hope I
never stop
renumber 46 increase your attraction we
spend over forty seven percent of our
time when the browsing the internet or
on our mobile phones procrastinating and
we check our phones around eighty six
times per day put your hand up if you
check-in more than that so it's no
surprise that we all face distraction we
all experience distraction we're all
played by distraction but often we think
that the opposite of distraction is
focus we think that we need to become
more focused we think that if we're
focused we'll feel less distracted we
feel that if we're able to draw our
energy in a certain direction and force
ourselves to absorb in an activity then
we won't be as distracted but this is
just not true the opposite of
distraction is actually not focus the
opposite of distraction
is way for attraction let me explain
what I mean
when we're attracted to something we
completely fixated we're completely
absorbed we are almost addicted and
obsessed to that visual that song what
we really need to do is increase our
attraction when we are attracted to
something when naturally focused we're
naturally able to be present we're
naturally able to bring our attention
and our energy to that task that project
that person when we're distracted and
don't have that attraction we're
naturally all over the place we end up
feeling lost confused and end up for
crass amazing as you can see we are
procrastinating and distracting others
so now know you're thinking how do you
get attracted to things that you're not
attracted to we all have things in life
that we love to do and we all have
things in life that we have to do let's
take the example of your job it's
something that you have to do it's
something that you may not be attracted
to when you ask yourself why do I go to
my job maybe the answer is it pays my
bills maybe the answer is it allows me
to take care of my family
maybe you studied for years and feel
that your job at least engages you for
that whichever one your answer is that
starts providing some value to why you
do that activity when you know that you
recognize that you are attractive to be
there because it serves a particular
purpose
you start become attracted because
whenever your mind says to you I'm bored
I'm distracted
I'm unfocused you say no I'm here
because it puts food on the table I'm
here because it pays my bills and takes
care of my family I'm here because I
studied and worked hard for this you
aren't able to increase your attraction
to even the things you're totally
unfocused on now if you found yourself
distracted on focus for too long that
definitely can mean that you need to
find more meaningful fulfilling work but
no matter what
no matter how much you chase your
passion and live your purpose it will
still be things you have to do on a
daily basis that you don't find
interesting and naturally you will feel
unfocused and distracted for that ask
yourself this question why am I here why
am I doing this and you'll find the mind
will start to become attracted to that
activity task or even that person rule
number 47 serve this two-year-old girl
was watching a cartoon in her parents
living room at one point one of the
cartoon characters started to cry you
can actually see the tears coming out of
their eyes this young girl grabbed a
tissue from the living room walked up to
the television and started to wipe the
screen trying to wipe the tear of this
cartoon character it was an incredible
show of kindness compassion empathy and
love from this two-year-old girl she
truly believed that the cartoon
character was crying and that her with
the tissue would be able to wipe away
its tears there's one of the most
beautiful things I've ever seen and that
was when I realized that we're wired for
generosity but educated for greed when
we're young we have this energy to give
to serve to be compassionate to be
loving to be kind but as we go through
life when we're faced with people being
extremely challenging when we're faced
with manipulation when we're faced with
people we don't trust that also makes us
close up I gotta pick a cabinet to hurt
him what can you do today that could
make a difference in someone else's life
what could you say to someone today that
would absolutely change their week or
their year what is the one thing you can
do that can truly change the experience
of even just one person on the planet
think about it my favorite quote from
Muhammad Ali is that service to others
is the rent we pay for our room here on
earth rule number 48 be a storyteller
are you a motivational speaker is that
what you do I like to call myself a
storyteller because I feel what I'm
trying to do is tell the stories that we
all live and I was just sharing with you
earlier that I genuinely believe that
the answers that people are looking for
inside of them and I'm just helping
people excavate and become
archaeologists and and kind of dig in
and find that through them so I don't
call myself a motivational speaker
because people may watch my videos and
it may not be motivational it may be
reflective it may be introspective it
may be insightful it may be emotional it
may even take people to a place they
don't want to go so I love being sharing
my stories as a storyteller simply what
I do is make wisdom go viral I have this
fascination with wisdom insight deep
thought and I believe that that wisdom
belongs to each and every person on the
planet
yeah and so my desire is to scale that
through entertainment through
storytelling through video in a way that
wisdom becomes accessible relevant and
completely involved and engaged in
people's daily lives
rule number 49 recognize that you're an
instrument and there's a beautiful story
of Benjamin Franklin that he had his
thirteen precept
before he died he had 13 qualities that
he wanted to attain in life before he
passed away they included things like
integrity simplicity honesty virtue etc
and at the end of his life he was asked
which one did you not attain when he
said the 13 one and they said what was
that is a humanity the reason why I'm
sharing that story is because the way
you overcome your ego is to recognize
that you're simply a channel or an
instrument when you recognize that your
instrument and whether you believe in
the universe whether you believe in
power whether you just believe in
mentorship you recognize that everything
you're giving is because someone's given
to you and someone's given to that
person and therefore you're becoming a
vessel an instrument of vehicle for the
greatest powers in the world and just
being a channel for that and that allows
you to fuel two things one thing is you
feel liberated because now it's no
longer your burden the second thing that
it does is that it allows you whenever
your ego gets in the way insist
we're doing well like I did that I
didn't you start recognizing and you get
perspective in gratitude I don't know
actually I'm gonna pause this whatever
Goods happening my life pause it to my
teachers positive people that shared it
with me because there is no one who is
self-made we talked about self
mayonnaise there was no one that works
even exist yeah because no one none of
us are self-made I'm not self-made
you're right
all I'm saying is just that if we all
truly reflect and we go I don't want to
be anyone watching to think I have to be
self-made
because if you ask him self-made then
you're gonna have to self all - yeah
right and everything will be self self
self when you fall on your own and you
rise on your own and rule number 50 the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is choose change over regret
[Music]
[Applause]
healing is so not about getting over
stuff and it's so much about getting
free stuff and I think we have this
mental block in thinking I need to get
over this rather than get through it and
when you try and get over something you
don't necessarily process the fame you
don't necessarily give yourself the time
and the energy and the care to express
how you fell and allow yourself a outlet
to really let go yeah and that's coming
from the point of view realizing that
regret is painful change is painful but
change is less painful than regret and
so when you realize that actually the
only two options I have now I regret or
change and they both her
but change hurts less and when we
recognize that then we choose to change
we choose to move forward we choose to
let go of that regret because we realize
that regrets not serving us
now I've got a really special bonus kit
from Jay on how to have a head a heart
and a hand that I think you're really
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the three-point landing questions
time to move from just watching another
video to taking action in your life or
business and if you're feeling bold
leave your answers in the comments below
here we go question number one where do
you need to choose change over regret in
your life number two how can you serve
others better and number three what does
your mini dream look like
so in an ideal life for me is a life and
this applies to a company and
organization and institution for me is
an ideal life is when we all have a head
a heart and a hand all three elements
together working in alignment without
one or the other we start to lose
something if you only are the head in a
heart you'll find that life is stable
and defined yes yeah sure sure sure sure
so a head is the clarity of vision what
you want what you want knowing what you
want the way you picture life and being
able to navigate make the decisions to
get that that's a good head a good heart
is being able to understand what your
intuition and heart one's being able to
connect and tap into that understanding
deeper and beyond the vision you may
have painted for yourself so I often say
to people that you get to where you want
in life just not in the way you imagined
and that's because the path that's paved
up and down is far different to the PUF
repave so you can have a great head and
a great vision and a great mission and
know where you want to go but if your
heart's not able to have that resilience
and be able to adapt and and have
compassion and care and all of that then
then you're not going to be able to make
the toughest decisions without your
heart but to be able to realize that we
need to care and be sustainable and
long-lasting requires a heart and a hand
is that service wanting to pass that on
that which you have wanting to give it
forward pay it forward the idea of
serving with what you have I often say
to people your passion is for you your
purpose is for others your passion makes
you happy but when you use your passion
to make a difference in someone else's
life that's a service that's a purpose
and that's the hand so those are my
three elements of an ideal life if you
want some more jay Shetty motivation
check out the video right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there no matter
what you choose to do
we'll always be people and find fault
with it everyone should become rich
famous and achieve everything they want